I think the biggest news of the week is
Travis Kelsey and Taylor Swift now T
cows is my boy and that boy's a dog he's
a girl but shoot at T Swift hold on
quick timeline Travis had his podcast
when he went into a concert and tried to
give her his phone number rules came out
they were hanging out Travis went on
McAfee dropped the line about Arrowhead
and then we see our Arrowhead yo okay
hold on this is where things get like
suspenseful hold on traffic when I saw
that video I almost lost my mind for you
like is she saying to you at night bro
you belong with me yes I am a Swifty I'm
the old Swift though you know when she
was out there saying like she wears
short skirts and I wear t-shirts big
hype for you dog I mean damn you shot
from Diva you score you Stephen Curry my
brother you might be the new stuff of
football that's dope I want to see
someone shoot at somebody else the NFL
we up right now City Boys is up hey I
challenge all my other NFL guys start
shooting from D shoot from d